if you think back to all the negative
situations you had like the really
really bad ones when you expand the time
Horizon most times they become net wins
and so then it just means that like if
you're in a really tough time right now
you just got to wait because most times
when is bad it can't get worse and
then your action threshold decreases and
you do all the things you know you
should have done anyways and so it's
like we have this big stack of should do
and we just wait until it's 2 miles and
you're like well I just fired one person
or like I just ended one partnership I
just broke up with one girl or whatever
it is and you're like who else do I need
to talk to today like